good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone i'm glad to be here to share
our recent research in self-supervised
learning called self-supervised learning
these entangled group representations as
features
as it's a recent conference submission
you can consider my talk as a trader
please keep tuned and check our website
for four piece in late september
the south
supervised learning first learns a
generic feature representation for
example a future backbone by training
with unsupervised pretext tasks such as
preventing contrastive objective
and then the above stage one feature is
expected to survey with stage two
applications with downstream fine tuning
so
what does ssl learn
features
how does ssl learn
contrastive loss but why does this
pipeline learn group features to answer
this question we first need to know what
is feature
we are interested in a more fundamental
definition of feature
features represent the semantic meanings
of the world
and the difference between two features
reflects the semantic change
say how to change from dark to cat
furthermore if this change is equivalent
with the feature this feature is a valid
representation of the change
this actually belongs to the group
theory
for simplicity you can consider the
group at the set of verbs acting on
these images
for example a group action can be
painting an image from red to green
so how to embed this group action we
first start from one group action and
still use the color change at the
example
the key is to first collect the training
data affected by the group action
inspired by the kd theorem any group is
isomorphic to a permutation group or its
subgroup
in our example the permutation is a kind
of sample sorting
from a random sorting to another sort
red digits are moved to the left while
green digits are moved to the right
then we simply divide such samples into
two subsets
here comes the partition
given the data partition we need a
learning objective besides the
conventional contrast of loss we also
have the invariant risk minimization
loss which regularizes the loss to be
invariant across different subsystem
partition
to achieve this imbalance the model need
to decompose a separate feature subspace
to encode the color semantic
just isolate the effect of the color
across different
subsets
in this way color semantic is recognized
and learned
this learning objective is also named as
minimization step in our work
after introduction how to learn one
group action into the feature
now we can answer the question can we
achieve a good feature in general
ssl should learn to embed all the
semantics and these semantics are
disentangled in vector space we name
this as disintegral representation
in general we propose a classic world
model of visual
representation to define the disintegral
representation using group zero the
disentangle has two concepts
first
equivalent
this was discussed just now that is
changing the semantic red to grain in
the u space is equivalent to change the
color vector in the axis from the value
encoding red to green
second
decomposable
for example changing the color semantic
does not affect the dj vector in x-space
recall that we have introduced how to
disentangle one group action in the
feature space using the minimization
step similarly the key to disentangle
another new feature is to find a new
partition set
let's think reversely in an informal but
intuitive way
if we can learn one disintended feature
then we can minimize this objective its
control position is that
if we maximize the object
the objective
we can find an entangled feature
we prove that the arc max p is acted by
a group action whose representation is
not disintegral
then these two steps can be iterated
onto convergence
for example as showing the left figure
the discover partition is based on the
group acting on the color semantic
subset number one is almost green while
subset number two is red
note that our maximization step can be
considered as active causal intervention
of the data which is fundamentally
different from the conventional
statistical learning that are proved
unable to
disentangle features
can existing ssl methods lead to the
disentangle representations
the answer is no
on the left-hand side we compare the
representation learned by
the same clear and our iperm algorithm
on stl10 dataset we report the knn
classification accuracy using the
augmentation equivalent features and the
augmentation unrelated features
respectively
we can find scene clear mostly
contributes to the first part
demonstrating that the other parties
still use this at the features of steel
nintendo
on the right hand side we show the image
semantics captured by the features of
the cn and background
for the rightmost example such as a
building image our eye term
representation at the 29th layer roughly
disentangles the rectangular building
the stairs the
sitting during monuments and the site
buildings into different feature maps
while steam clear entangles all of them
the latter figure visualizes the
features learned by the same clear and
our eye perm on the colored and nice
data set
for sinclair features it is obvious that
there is no clear boundary to
distinguish the semantic of the cutters
in the same clear feature space besides
the features of the same digit semantics
are scattered in two regions
for our iperm
the features are well clustered the
feature space has the
metric structure for each individual
semantic
validating the decomposable property of
item representation
we also explore how does i term these
entangled features
this visualization corresponds to the
maximization step
we can get the flowing conclusions first
for example in prediction one
red and green digits are separated
besides of the obvious semantics such as
the digit and colored
labeling the first
line and the second line we can also
discover a new semantic the slot
in this figure we aim to visualize how
equivalent each feature dimensions to
the change of each semantic the dark
color shows that a dimension is more
equivalent with respect to the semantic
indicated on the right we can see that
seeing clear fails to learn the
decomposable representation
in contrast iperm achieves disentangled
representation by representing the
semantics into separate dimensions
on both color and nice and shape 3d data
set i turn significantly outperformed
same clear regarding all the metrics
we demonstrate our results and compare
with baselines in both tables
incorporating
iperm to the three baselines brings
consistent performance boosts to
downstream classification models in all
settings on all data sets
to sum up our community has already
reached the agreement that
self-supervised learning is very useful
but we still hunger for definitive
answer why it works i hope our work
using group theory as a fundamentally
different part of you can help you get
closer to the truth
end of my talk thank you very much
hi everybody i'm yuan wang from msre i
would like to introduce my research work
learning disentangled representation by
discovering preaching generating model
or contractive learning view
binger pointed out that for ai to
understand the world fundamentally the
only way is to identify and disentangle
the underlying explanatory factors of
the observed data
given observed images of 3d sense for
this toy example the underlying
explanatory factors are the camera pose
object shape and so on
with those factors
we can generate and control the images
with this disentangled factors
independently
for disentangled representation learning
the goal is to learn to extract search
representations of the factors from
their images
here is a toy example we have the ground
truth of factors
but for real world data typically we
need to learn disentangled
representation in an unsupervised manner
this entangled representation learning
is important for both fundamentals and
applications
for fundamentals it can help the
interpretability reasoning concept
learning and so on for applications it
can benefit controllable generation
editing domain generation and so on
for example given a dog image with
disentangled representation it is
possible to control the images according
to the text
makes the dog happy makes their eye
bigger while keeping other attributes
same
this entanglement is raising a lot of
attention and there are increasing works
on it
it is one of the top 50 keywords in this
year's iclear submissions
let's revisit some of the milestone
works in this literature
the conceptual definition is proposed by
banjor in 2013.
after that
to achieve unsupervised disentanglements
some works tried ad hoc implementation
by ending an extra disentanglement
regularization to generating model such
as vae of gap for example the
regularization in the e-based model is a
total correlation of the latent variable
distribution however this regularization
results in a trade-off between the
disentanglement and the generation
quality
then in 2019
small past paper challenged these
methods and pointed out that
only the regularization is not enough to
achieve unsupervised disentanglement
how to achieve unsupervised
disentanglement is a challenging task
fundamentally those masters try to
fulfill three tasks similar
simultaneously the first one is
discovering the generative factor and
second one is learning or generative
generator or decoder to
generate images from generative factors
and the third one is learning an encoder
to encode images to disentangled
reputation for these factors
so the fundamental is that
we do these three tasks together and we
have a trade-off
so
it is possible to do these three tasks
separately and get rid of the trade-off
we proposed this code to learn
disentangled representation by
discovering pre-trained generative model
from a contracted learning view
this code is inspired over some previous
work
giving a preaching generating model
without any disentanglement
regularization
when traversing along different
directions in the latent space the
generated samples show different
variations
this indicates that
there are disentanglement properties
embedded in the latent space
if we can find the directions
of distinct image variations for example
one changes the background color and one
change the object color
then according to the goal of
disentangled representation learning
the directions can be treated as a
factors
to learn the disentangle representation
we use the encoder to extract the
representation from their images
this code provides an alternative route
for disentangled representation learning
instead of doing the three tasks
simultaneously
we leverage the pre-trained generative
models with high generation quality and
focusing on jointly discovering the
directions in the latent space
and learn disentangle reputations
from the contractive learning view
starting with the image variation of
pre-trained generating model we have a
more effective way to achieve
disentangled representation learning
here is the framework of disco
in our pre-trained generative model we
fixate
then we use the navigator to discover
the directions in the latent space
as their factors to generate image
variations between the image pairs
then we use the disentangling encoder to
extract the representation from the
image pairs
to model the variations between the
would build their variation space
based on their encoded representations
by pulling together similar variations
and push away different variations
we jointly train the navigator and the
encoder to make the navigator discover
distinct directions and the encoder
extract disentangle representations
by leveraging the pre-tuned genetic
model in this way will ensure the high
generation quality and do not have the
trade-off between disentanglement and
generation quality
here is a counter detail results disco
achieves the state of the art
disentanglement on three popular data
sites and two disentanglement metrics
this code can also work for the current
majority generative models include gun
way and flow
compared with the previous methods
due to getting rid of the trade-off this
code has much brighter image
generation quality and achieve wider
disentanglement at the same time
with disco we can control the
overexposed or photo or make her face
smile while keeping other attributes the
same
for cat image we can change the color of
the cat to be black
or make their eyes smaller
here is our evaluation of the discovered
directions
where children still other odds result
compared to other latent discovery
methods
to wire five sides the variation and the
contrast either k for disco we do the
ablation study by replacing variation
with concrete operation or replacing
their concrative laws with
classification laws
the performance drops a lot
only with contractive loss under
variation space we can better discover
the generative factors and learn
disentangled reputations
as a conclusion this entangled
representation learning is a fundamental
task which is a key for general ai and
can be and can benefit a lot too by
applications
this entangled leverage pre-trained
generation models and proposed a
constructive learning view for
disentangled representation learning
currently our method highly relies on
the disentangled property of the latent
space
of the pre-triune generative model the
next step is to demystify the
disentanglement property in pre-trained
generative model and achieve better
disentangle representation learning
that's the end of my presentation and
thanks for your time
hello everyone i'm shooting a faculty
member at the uit the arctic university
of norway i'm also affiliated with the
norwegian visual intelligence center
it's my honor to have the opportunity to
present overwork making deeper neural
networks transparent by information
theory at the microsoft research summit
this is a joint work with my supervisor
dr jose principe at the university of
florida and my colleagues at the uit the
university of kentucky and the nec labs
europe
we know that the deeper neural networks
are all around us
we have successful applications in
self-driving cars
in speech recognition in energy
analytics and in healthcare
however
it has been a long time that people
blame that deeper neural networks is a
black box because the there are only a
few theoretical observations to explain
their great success
so indeed there are still some
fundamental problems
concerning the deeper neural networks
for example the interpretability
questions include why did a trinidad
network reach a certain decision or
which components of the input do
contribute most
on the other hand we also want to
understand
the generalization behavior or a deeper
neural network when it was trained from
scratch so question then includes why do
deeper neural neural network perform
very well or how to improve the
generalization ability of deeper neural
net to out of distribution data
our work in the last few years focus on
using the methodology of information
theory to answer questions above and or
try to give some insights to the above
questions
currently the information theory has
gradually become popular methodology in
various machine learning or computer
vision tasks
and the popular examples include
to use information theory to explain or
identify the most influential facial
data to the decision or understand the
general behavior of deeper neural
networks in the training phase example
include the information board next
theory
or identify the fundamental properties
or derive a tighter generation bond of
deep learning or figure out the inner
working mechanism behind different
neural neural nets such as the principle
of rate reduction
so in this talk i will briefly introduce
some of the work from our group in this
area
in order to apply information theory to
various machine learning or computer
vision tasks the most important or first
step is to have a way such that we can
effectively quantify information
theoretical quantities such as entry or
divergence ordering from samples this is
just because the traditional challenge
entry function such as entropy the
divergence or mutual information
are all defined over the probability
distribution function of the data
however we know that in most of the
cases the distribution of data are
unknown
and
moreover
to
the effective estimation of the
probability probability distributions in
high dimensional space is a very very
hard or even infeasible problem in
either machine learning or statistics so
our question is that
if it is possible to estimate
information theoretical quantities such
as divergence between information or
entropy
without resorting to the estimation of
the underlying probability distribution
the answer is yes in our recent work in
transaction on information theory and
transaction pattern analysis and motion
intelligence
we defined the matrix-based anterior
functional and we showed that
we can't define
entropy or mutual information or
divergence just use the eigen spectrum
of positive definite metrics generated
from given samples
for example if we want to estimate the
entropy or total uncertainty of variable
x suppose i have n samples x1 x2 and xn
each x i is in d dimensional space so
instead of evaluate its underlying
probability description p x
what we did is just to first evaluate a
gram matrix k of the size n by n and we
show that
we can't define the total uncertainty or
entropy of x just to use the eigenvalues
of the normalized gram matrix a
in our recent works we also show that
the matrix based android function is
automatically differentiable which means
that which means that it can naturally
be embedded
into a deep learning for the training or
some other tasks
now
based on the state-of-the-art estimators
on anti-fundamental information we begin
to use information theory to explore
some fundamental properties behind
deeper neural networks
so the most famous information
theoretical principle in deep learning
is the information botnet
given input x and the desired output y
the information botnet formulates the
learning problem
formulated as a tradeoff between
maximization between the mutual
information of y and t
minus the beta of the mutual information
between x and t
the first term the mutual information
between y and t candy can be understand
as a sufficiency or
the predictive performance of t on task
y on the other hand for the second term
the mutual information between x and t
can be understand as a complexity of the
reputation of t
so with the state of that the matrix
based anti-functional
we measure the mutual information values
between x t and between y and t
in the training of deeper neurons and we
plot the information plane the x-axis of
the information plane is a mutual
information between x and t and the y
axis of the mutual information plane is
mutual information between y and t
the
dark blue point here it's a mutual
information values at the beginning of
the training and the green point is the
mutual information values at the middle
of the training
whereas the yellow points here it's a
mutual information values at the end of
training and we can see that there are
obvious two phases in the training of
the
in the first phase
the mutual information values increase
drastically
however in the second phase the mutual
information value especially the mutual
information between x and t will begin
to decrease which means that there is a
natural compression for the latent
reputation
and
all the uh although this observation i
mean the fitting phase and the
compression phase is still controversial
issue in the community
however based on other recent studies
based on the metrics based on functional
and all the results from our peers we
gradually believe that this phenomenon
is common to deep neural net and
especially for the convolutional neural
networks
on the other hand we want to say that
the information botnet principle also
has its practical usage on applications
including the interpretability for
example in the problem of state and
detection we can just imagine t
as the most informative component to our
decision y
similarly for the problem uh in natural
language processing if we want to
explain
based on the sentence i cough a lot at
night to decide if i have a flu or not
then i can just generate a binary mask
and then
put the mask on the sentence of the eggs
to generate a compressed repetition
which only contains two most informative
words cough and night only based on the
two most imp
informative words cough and night i can
decide if it's a flu or not
in other groups they also use
information theory to improve the
generalization performance of deep
learning for example for the problem of
classification on the covalent shift
which means that the distribution of x
changes but the distribution of y given
x remain the same
we have proved and validated that
if
the distribution of prediction residue y
minus fx is independent to the
distribution of x
then our model is robust against
chromosome shift if and only if such
criterion is satisfied moreover we also
prove that this loss function can also
encourage the model is robust against
noise in the label
in our recent work we also show how to
use information botanic principle
and how to learn a discrete date or soft
mask on the raw features such that it
can progressly drop out the spurious
correlations and only remains or the
causal attributes in our data site such
as mechanics can also improve the
generation of dependent net in
sequential environment
the conclusion of my talk is that we
have proposed a matrix-based
anti-functional and we show how to use
it in understanding and regeneration of
deep neural network however we also want
to say there are many other more
opportunities to use information theory
beyond information botnet such as the
the principles rate reduction the rate
of distortion functions
thanks